so we were dealing with construction you
know we've been dealing with it this
week it's been not great but not nearly
as bad last week was horrible week
before was tough I didn't notice it you
have not know how okay because we put
out a video and it seemed like you
noticed it it's something you mildly
from your reaction similar you're taking
great joy in my reaction to all of it
yeah there's a lot of construction still
happening yeah that's still going on
Detroit said that he wanted to turn a
negative into a pond or destroys the
he's known around these hallways as an
eternal optimist yes yes you know that's
that's the thing about Troy yes he
always is looking on the bright side yes
he is
you know I'm trying to take lemons and
make lemonade Danny you always say that
you know and so you created a game for
us very quick game okay Rick what is it
it's called construction sound name that
tune that's good that's good and you
took some of these construction sounds
and only wanted to use the construction
sounds right so I really set a goal for
myself
sure uh-huh don't use any other
instruments any other sounds it's just
the sounds that came through these
microphones all right should we play the
first one then this is the Troy Quon
game construction name that tune yep I
[Music]
got it back of black is that right by
ac/dc stress that's great that's the
sounds of drilling right yeah the
hammering was the beat right that's
smart so you get a you get they actually
use in the phones that's only the sounds
yeah oh right yeah the I was gonna say
it sounds very industrial but that's
probably because it was made using
construction noise yes like the actual
sounds of what that is yeah okay do we
have a second song oh yeah
it's great
you can kind of hear his faintly
complaining over it yeah that sounds
really like yeah that's great they've
been amazing how much clear audio Tory
had to work with it wouldn't seem like
this would be an impossible task yeah
but there was enough construction sound
to work with that you were able to make
several songs yeah yeah this is great
all right well it Travis you said the
first two words that was very easy yes
those were the easiest one that's all
right and I feel like that was a that
was a layup for Jim - that was a little
hoarse yeah yeah that's that's good okay
all right there's a third one there are
yes there is
okay other side the beautiful people
[Music]
this is awesome yeah good pick okay I
think I hope
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna guess screaming for vengeance
it's definitely Metallica right yep
you're on the right track okay it's it
sounds like pop ahem
[Applause]
[Music]
master puppets there it is we did that
one together that's us together yeah yep
look at what happens when we put these
internet dick brains together right we
go one more one more
I'm cheating I mean doing master of
puppets with the construction sounds
that seems that that's pretty
complicated yeah yeah that's great but
could you hit pause for a second first
of all I think I know it but there was
actually construction playing live while
that construction was playing so the
back story threw me off a little bit
there was real construction still going
on so well but I think I know
[Music]
[Music]
yeah is it a newer song oh maybe I'm
wrong
it kind of sounds like Beverly Hills by
Weezer kind of sounds like it guys and
once I did this one I thought that I
also thought Joan Jett yeah but it's not
those know it this one didn't turn out
that great what band I mean it's pretty
fabulous given what the materials that
were working with the band would be
Whitesnake he didn't Whitesnake so I
might I know this you heard the
construction sounds and you're like I
should make a Whitesnake so I did a
bunch yeah of course
yeah I just couldn't place it
yeah I can hear it now but I wouldn't
have gotten that without the whites take
him now use a drum on this or that the
hammering what happened below us I think
you can hear em they're clear as a bell
I see
very creative Wow good job man those are
great yeah one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM avid